it is such a great question because
leadership has anyone who knows can be
lonely it can be thankless it can be
exhausting and to find that energy is
unbelievably difficult and the way you
find that energy is from other people
this whole obsession we have right now
with work/life balance it makes me a
little uncomfortable because it means
that our work and our life are in
opposition because that's what balance
is right it's the balancing of opposing
forces but the only difference between
work and life is the clothes we wear in
the table we sit at it's us
the reason our friends love us is the
same reason our colleagues love us right
and so the energy that we get won't come
from yoga right you like you can do more
yoga and you can meditate a little
longer and you'll feel amazing after
your yoga class and you'll still hate
the next day at work right the energy
that we have to keep doing it comes from
our friends it comes from our support
networks invest in in in in deep
meaningful relationships so often we're
so busy at work that we neglect our
friends so busy were sometimes are so
busy at work we neglect those who love
us and when push comes to shove we risk
them not being there for us when we need
them because we weren't there for them
when they needed us and sometimes we
have to make sacrifices for them if we
have any hope that they will make
sacrifices for us I've had the
opportunity to meet people who who
really did risk who risk their lives to
save the lives of others and through
some miracle didn't die and yet they
thought they would when they risk their
lives these heroes and I've had the
chance to ask them why did you do it
you've got a family you've got children
no one would've ordered you to do what
you did and no one would have faulted
you if you didn't you chose to do these
things sometimes disobeyed an order to
do these things why did you do it and
they all give the same answer because
they would have done it for me it's the
undying belief that our friends will be
there for us every single one of us
building a business playing the infinite
game living life it's really really hard
and none of us has the strength to do it
alone none of
it takes help huge amounts of help we
need people to say when we're down when
we doubt ourselves to say I believe in
you you got this I've got your back
I'm here I need you to keep doing this
we need you to keep doing this we need
people in our lives to encourage us and
inspires if we're going to encourage and
inspire others
[Music]